よろしくお願いします
心の説明に入りまして
前回は 貪瞋痴のやつ終わりましたと思います
で まあちょっと繰り返して申し上げますけど
心っていうのはなかなかこのたくさんあるわけじゃないし
たった一つの働きは心というんですね
ものを認識すること そちらには線も枠も何もない
ただ認識するという機能だけなんですね
心っていうのは 何か認知する
知る いわゆる知る機能に心というんです
ですから 物体でも物質的なものでも
何か魂みたいな 何か霊的なものでもないんですね
そういうのはこの人間が考え出す幻想であるというのが仏教の話なんです
ですから この質的な実体的なものではなくて
ただのFunction
ただの働きだという知的な知という働き
知るという働きに心と呼んでいる
だから知るということでいうと
別に何を知るかということによって
心は別に変化するわけじゃないとは考えられるんですね
世の中にあるものは ただ
例えば見るならば いろんなものを見る
ただそれだけのこと でも
残念ながら 見るものによって心は変化してしまっちゃうし
聞くものによって心が変化してしまっちゃうし
考えるものによって心が変化してしまっちゃうんですね
そこで我々は心の変化を感じて
いろんな心があるんじゃないかなと思っちゃうんですね
例えば怒りの心 欲の心
怠けの心 楽しい心 悲しい心
あるんじゃないかなと
汚れている心 清らかな心とかあるんじゃないかなと思ったりする
まあそういうのはまあないわけじゃないんだけど
でもそれ見るもの 聞くもの
考えることによって心に来る変化で
このなぜ変化が来るかということは別な枠で我々は考えているんです
で 心ということだけを言うと
一つしかないという話は
ずっと何回も何回も繰り返して申し上げました
そこで それでも我々には心の変化は見えます
それはどういう風な変化かというと
僕は例えで言ったんだから
その例えを考え出すとよくわかると思います
例えばこの水なんですね
水っていうのは本当は一つしかないんですが
我々にはもう海水もありますし
井戸水もあります 水道の水もあります
いろんな水やら飲み物やらもう数え切れないほど世の中にあるんですね
なんで井戸の水と海水は違いますかと
というと 水自体は違うわけじゃなくて
海の水の場合はもう溶けているものと
井戸の水の場合はそちらに溶けているものはそれぞれ違いますから
我々はこれは井戸の水で
これは海水ですよと言うんですね
ですから本当は同じく心は同じですけど
心に溶けているものによって我々は区別を考えているんです
これ私は怒っているんですよというと
心があって そこに怒りがある
私は悲しいが悲しいですよという場合は
そこに心があって 悲しみというものが入っていると
そういうことでたくさん心が考えられるのです
その そういうものであるならば
水と同じくもう数え切れないほどの心の種類は考えられるんですね
そうするとあまりにも数え切れないんだから
もうそれは学問にはならないんですね
そこである学問という角度で
尺度で 立場でいくらかのまとめやまとめをしなくちゃいけない
そこで仏教でこういう話を喋っているんだから
仏教に必要な側面で心理学者に必要な側面ではないんです
一般的な社会の人に必要な側面ではなくて
仏教に必要な側面で枠に入れているんですね
仏教というのはやっぱり修行という目的があって
心を清らかにすること
あるいは解脱するという目的がありまして
だから解脱するために必要な心理学を作って
それに必要な心の分析を言っているんですね
それは大雑把に 一般的に人間の心の分析にもなるんです
なぜならば 一般の人が修行して解脱するんだから
普通の人の心の分析にもなるんです
でも ヨーロッパの心理学みたいな目的とは違うんですね
ですから 僕らから見れば
ヨーロッパの心理学は一般の人の心の分析であって
一般の人の心が別に成長しようとか
そういう何とかしようという気持ちではないんです
それはあくまでもヨーロッパの心理学は医学の概念から発展して出てきた
枝分かれしたものだから
医学っていうのは 人は普通であって健康的であると
その普通の状態はもうちょっと落ち込んだら
堕落しちゃったら病気ですよと言って
そのレベルが落ちたところから
もうちょっと普通のレベルに持ち上げられるようなことは医学というんですね
同じくヨーロッパの心理学では
普通の人間は健康な心を持ってるんだと
その普通のレベルがちょっと
おかしくなっちゃったらその人は精神的な病気ですよと
ですから それはなぜかと勉強して
落ちたのはなぜかと勉強して
その落ちたレベルから普通のレベルに持ち上げてあげる
それが心理学なんです
ですから ヨーロッパの心理学で医学で見えるのは悪い方の研究だけなんですね
医学勉強すると病気の勉強しなくちゃいけないんですね
健康な状態の勉強はしないんです
心理学の場合も 精神的な弱いことのいろいろコンプレックス
何々コンプレックス ああだこうだとか
そういうもののことを勉強しなくちゃいけない
そこで普通の状態に戻ってあげようと努力する
まあ医学は成功していないと同時に
心理学も成功していないんですね
人々はいくら医学が発展したっても
我々は病気ですから 病気が消えることはありませんし
同じく まあそれは推測なんですけど
まあ現状でもありますが
心理学はいくらヨーロッパ的に発展していても
人の精神的な病気は治すくはないと
永遠にそれは続けてしまっちゃうんですね
で 仏教の場合はそのノーマルな状態のところからいかに人を成長しますかと育ててあげますかという方向を見ているんですね
ですから 仏教の心理学の場合は
別に人の精神的な病気の研究とか出てこないんですね
で なぜ人は病気になりますか？どうやって病気になりますか？という話も出てこないんです
その代わりにいかにより健康的になるかという
例えば体の状態になってくると
お釈迦様は食べ物についてあまり食べるなとか
いくらお腹が満腹になるまで食べるなとかね
まあいろいろそういうことを言っていて
もうよくもう寝ることはものすごく怒ったりして
寝っぱなしで死ぬなとか
で ちゃんと体を洗いなさいとかね
そういうことにはものすごく厳しく言ってるんですね
その場合は 健康な人の状態がもう堕落しないで
よりいい方向へ持っていくためのものなんですね
ですから この普通の状態
ゼロと考えちゃうと ヨーロッパ的な知識では
このマイナスのレベルの人々がゼロのところまで持ってくる学問であって
仏教というのはゼロのレベルにいる人が限りなくポジティブのプラスの方向へ持ち上がるための教えになっているんですね
そういう点で仏教学は
ヨーロッパ 現代の普通の学問とはそういう点では違うんですね
ですから 仏教では病気だと言っているのは病気の人ではないんです
本当にバリバリ健康的な人々なんです
仏教で愚か者っていうのは
普通の人々のレベルで見れば
ものすごい抜群の知識人たちなんですね
一般の人から愚か者というのは
仏教ではもうもう考えもされない
遠い人々なんです 一般の人から愚か者と言われるのは
もう0以下にマイナスレベルのいる人々だから
仏教で愚か者っていうのは
まあごく普通にものすごくもう健康的で
バリバリと行動しているものすごい知識人たち
愚か者たちと怒ったりして
頑張りなさいと なぜ怠けるかと
そこで努力すれば もう普通の人間のレベルを超えて超えていっちゃうんですね
だから仏教の世界でよくお釈迦様はよく使っている言葉がございますが
ウッタリマヌッシャダンマという
[背景音楽]ウッタリマヌッサダンマというパーリ語の言葉がよく出てきて
で アリアという言葉もありまして
アリアダンマ ウッタリマヌッサダンマとか
で ウッタリというのは英語で言えばスーパーという意味で
スーパー  S U P E R まああまりこの英語を使っちゃったら
日本語でも使ってるんだから
ちょっと意味が変わってしまっちゃいますけど
まあ日本語でスーパーとか何とか言ってますけど
まあスーパーってね まあ普通よりはすごい格が高いって意味なんですね
で 超という意味では超越の超
乗り越えている で マヌッサっていうのは人間
ダンマっていうのはまあ性質であって
まあ人間の次元というかね
人間のもう次元ですね
いわゆるマヌッサでノーマルという
まあ普通とでもいいし
だから普通の次元を乗り越えるという法則になっちゃうんですね
だからこの出家の人々には
仏教徒にお釈迦様はよく言うのは
あなたはウッタリマヌッサダンマ何か持ってますかと
いわゆる何か性格持ってますか
人間性を乗り越えている
人間の次元乗り越えている
何か持ってるんですか
何も持ってなかったらもう何の意味もないんだと
ただ人間で生まれて人間で生きてて人間に死んじゃっただけのことだから
何も成長していないんだから
ですから何か得なさい
自分の次元を乗り越えるものっていう
まあそういう世界は説明しているんですね
で アリアっていうのは聖なるという意味で
英語でノーベルというんですね
ですから この聖なる方
何か得なさいと ですから
お釈迦様の教えにはアリアダンマとかね
アリアーナダンもそういろいろ四聖諦にも四つの聖なる真理と
そちらに聖なるっていうのは
一般の人には考えられない高いレベルから見た真理であると
ごく普通の科学の真理とはもうものすごい桁が違うんということは徹底的に言うために
だから普通の人々は何かお釈迦様の教えはからかったりしますけど
なんでお釈迦さんがただすべては苦しんでいただけではないか
大した教えではないかと思ったりしますけど
まあまあそれはもう全く桁外れの仏教を知らない人の
未通の考え方で お釈迦様のドゥッカの教え
苦しみの教えっていうのは普通の人間には考えられるものではないんです
普通のどんな人にもそんなことが考えられるんだったら
聖なる教えではなくて
ごく一般的な教えになっちゃうんですね
ですから 仏教で言ってる苦
聖諦であろうとも それはもう大変高度な智慧で発見しなくちゃいけない高い真理になっているんです
そういうことで この仏教の世界っていうのは
やっぱり人間 一般の人々のところからどうやって成長するかっていうことの目的である教えなんですね
そこで心の分析になると
我々は一般的な心理学の世界で勉強しているような概念はほとんど出てこない
何々コンプレックスとか全く出てこない
で だから変ということじゃないんです
本当は心理学の人々は仏教の教えを勉強して
そちらから何か影響を受けた方が
より早く人々の心を直すことはできると思いますよ
だから仏教から見れば
こういう精神的な問題ある人っていうのを直すというのも
もういとも簡単なものなんですね
時間もかからないし すぐ直せられるんです
でもヨーロッパ的なやり方で言えば
もう何年も何年もかけてかけて直さなくちゃいけない
それでできない場合は薬でもあげたりして
薬に依存させたりでもして
何とかごまかすと その状態を
まあそういう風になっていて
じゃあ今日の話にこれから戻りますけど
そこで心の分析の場合も
我々の心のレベルを超越するときは理解しておかなくちゃいけない
基本的な知識 そのためにこのアビダンマで心の分析を行っていると思います
なんで私はこういうことを言いますかというと
この現代的な心理学の知識で見ると
なんか物足りないと感じるところはあるかもしれません
そうかなと思う時もいろいろあるかもしれません
でもそれは仏教は気にしない
一般の人々から見れば物足りない
あだこだとか言ったっても
例えば仏教で一番有名なのはこの無意識という概念がないことなんですね
心理学ではすごいもう抜群に考える概念で
仏教はもう九十八パーセントぐらい心理学なのに
なんで無意識という言葉がないんですかと
なんで夢の分析なんかないんですかと
あって何が悪いですと思うかもしれません
そこで物足りないと感じるかもしれません
仏教はそんなこと気にしない
夢の分析とか何の役に立つかということで
ただの夢だから そういうのはないんです
夢を分析して それからいろいろ推測して
この人はこういうことに病気になっているよとかね
まあバカなことをやってるんですね
仏教から見れば 人間にいろいろ余計な希望があったりして
希望が実現できなくなっちゃうと
失望感で落ち込んじゃう
ちょっとそれだけのこと
それは夢を分析しなくても
その人に聞けばね あなたは何になりたがってるんですかと
あなたはまあまあどういうどういう希望がありますかと聞けば
本人は知ってるんだから
ちょっと紙に書いてもらったら
あなたはどのような人間になりたいか書いてみろと
書いてみたこのリスト見たら
これはもうバカバカしいと本人に見えますからね
それで病気というのは治りますよ
別に何もしなくても それにものすごい分厚いテキストを 40冊ぐらい読んだりして
夢の分析と だから夢のために
ありとあらゆる文化の中でいろんなへんてこりんな概念がいっぱいありますからね
インドの夢の分析やら
中国 日本の夢の概念やら
ヨーロッパ的な夢の概念やら
そこをもう一生かかってしまっちゃうんですね
この精神分析とかでも
その人々もかなり苦労して
ありとあらゆる文化から情報を集めていっているだけで
同じ泥の沼の中でも情報を探していることだから
なかなか超越的な心理学にはならないんですね
だから我々はやっぱり無意識のない心のと無意識という概念ない心理学をこれからやるということを理解した方がいいんです
夢って何ですかと 夢の分析は出てこない
それでこのアビダンマっていうのはお坊さんたちが作った部分だから
自分のために作ったもんなんですね
それは この普通の人々に言おうと思って作ったものじゃないんです
ですから 決して読書にならないんです
アビダンマのテキストっていうのは
テキストあるし 英訳もあるし
アビダンマも 7冊の本がありますからね
まあ日本訳もあるし 読んでみてください
絶対全然わからないと思います
なんか最近なんか電話があって
僕はこの前この知恵の話をして
なかなか知恵の話はできなかったんだけど
その場合はまああるわけがあって
一応テキストだけ見せたんですね
このテキストではこの知恵の分析があります
それで電話があります
それでどういうテキストで書くこと読みたがってるんですね
これその人に言ったんで
いい加減にやめなさいと
読んだってわかりません
そんなこと だから まああまり欲をくばらないで
私が言ったことだけ聞いて
そんなもんかと それぐらいでもう全くそれしかないんです
なぜならば あのテキストを私が読んだっても
かなり頭からもう汗が出るんです
それはもう難しいんです
で まあまあ僕らはわかりますよ
なんでこういう風に書いてますかと
そういう意味とかね こういうこういうこと
だから早く読める 読めるし
まああるシステム 思考方法決まってるんだから
でも読書にはさっぱり全く
ただのリスト リスト リスト
リストだけで決まってる
カテゴリーの中に分けて分けて分けてリストで
それでも限りなくもうこれぐらいあります
これぐらいあります これぐらいあります
これぐらいありますとかね
それはそれだけで 誰か先生から教えてもらっちゃうと
すっごいもうすごい世界であるということはわかるかもしれませんだけど
それはもうやっぱりそれなりの人に読んでもらわない限りはわからないものなんですね
だから仏教にいろいろ文句言ったってもしょうがないんです
それはもう普通の人の知識とは関係ない
まあ超越した世界の話ですから
いわゆる超越した知識から見た普通の心の分析ですから
そこら辺もちょっとややこしいというか
難しいというかね まあそういうことで
このお坊さんたちが別に一般の人のことを構わず
それはどうでもいいということで
心の分析が出て まず出てくるのはこの不善神なんですか
善神はなんですか その両方にも入らない心はなんですかという 3つのカテゴリーなんです
ですから クサラダンマ
今日のテキストじゃなくて
これから本物のテキストから引用しますけれど
で クサラダンマ アクサラダンマ
アビダンマのテキストの経典というか
この三蔵経にアビダンマの部分に一番最初に出会う言葉はこれなんです
パッタカタマンクサラダンマアクサラダンマアッキャカタダンマ
その 3つのカテゴリー
クサラダンマっていうのは善なる法
アクサラダンマ 不善たる法
アッキャカタダンマ そういう判断できない法と
こちらで法というのは心と心に入っている心素
その順番でまず 3つに分けているんですね
ですから 仏教のアビダンマはクサラアクサラアッキャカタという 3つの立場から発展していってるんですね
ですから 心理学と同時に倫理学もあるんです
でもあるんですね そういう心理学
倫理学 社会学という分け方も仏教でないんです
いわゆるどんな教えであろうか
そこに倫理がなければダメなんですね
例えば仏教の経済学的な解釈がありますよ
お経の中で 仏教の経済学っていうのは倫理学なんです
社会では倫理っていうのは別に分けてやってるんだから
仏教から見れば これ不思議でしょうがない
人間は生きることは倫理であって
そこに正しき来るということがありますから
生きるんだから経済がありますから
生きるんだから政府がありますから
そこに倫理が要りませんというのはもう考えられないことなんですね
だから政治というのは人間の生きるために必要なものであって
そこに倫理はないんだと
それは考えられないことであって
ですから仏教というのはもう倫理学はもう専門なんです
その中の経済的な考え方やら社会的な考え方やら
まあなんだかんだで出てきて
例えば家族はどうやってあの幸福な家族を作りますかというと
そこにあるのは倫理学なんですね
いつでも そういう点で
あのまた仏教は一般の知識とは違うところなんですね
宗教ともまた違うところなんですね
宗教というのは現実の生きている社会は関係なく
死後のことを言ってるんですね
世の中の宗教っていうのは
死んでからの話なんですね
一般的な宗教は 仏教ではもう死んでからの話とかそんな考えてないんです
それ輪廻という概念があるんだからといって
仏教はもう死んでからの教えですと言うたら
ものすごいお釈迦さまはそれに反対しているんですね
今ここでと 今ここで体験するものだよと
お釈迦様はこう言うんですね
宗教はありまして  8つに分けて
4つはもうただのもう聞いただけでも嘘やと
もう次の 8つはちょっと考えちゃったらすごく
不満ですよ で 聞いただけでも嘘やというのは
例えば運命論 定め論に基づいている
全ては定めていて決まっているんだと
なんとなくすごい高い知識のように感じちゃうんですね
世の中よく観察して見てみましょうと
我々には何もできないのではないかと
全部決まってるんではないかと
例えば地震が起こることは我々は知りませんだけど
やっぱり地球の中の働きによっていつ起こるかという
それはもうちゃんと決まっていて
私たちはいつ病気になるかということはちゃんと決まっていて
知らないだけのことであって
決まってるんではないかと
ですから ある法則によって全部定められているんだと
その法則は神でもいいし
神でないただの法則でもいいんですね
ですから 仏教は別に特別に神様に神様を批判しようということじゃなくて
ただ定め論でまとめちゃうんですね
全部 定め何に定められているかということは
そのその宗教によって変わります
けど それはお釈迦様は聞いただけでも嘘やと言ってるんです
なぜかというと 全て定めてるんでったら
なんで人間努力しなくちゃいけないんですか？努力したって無意味でしょ
例えば私は病気になる定めであるならば
一生懸命運動して食べ物を食べて頑張ったって何の意味もないんです
私は銀行強盗になる定めであるならば
まあそのままでいいんです
別に 努力していい人になろうという考え方は必要でないんだと
だから強盗する人やら窃盗する人やら
よこしまな行為をする人やら
嘘つきやら そういう定めだからと
というと 社会には何も進歩なく
人間は何も努力しなくていけなくなっちゃうんだと
厳密に考えちゃうと でもそれ事実違うではないかと
だから聞いただけでも嘘だと
だから仏教ではこの絶対神ですか
そういうのはもう出てこない
もう話し相手にはならないんですね
あまりにも仏教から見ればあまりにもくだらなくて
まずそれはもう考えただけでも嘘やと
これ不満と言っているのは
このこういうお祈りすれば
こういう修行すれば あなたは死後天に生まれますよと
神と一体になりますよと言ったところで
それ死ななきゃわからないんですね
正しいか誤いかと 死んでから間違ったと分かったってもう遅いでしょうに
ですから 不満なんですね
あの宗教不完全なんですね
例えば現代あるキリスト教というのは
この 2つ性質持っているんですね
定め論の性質と 今言ったこの不完全な性質
それ合体して現代キリスト教ありまして
宗教というのはそういう性質はいくつか合体しているんです
で 何ですか この浄土真宗とかね
そういう あの まあこの
特にそういう親鸞系統の教えだったら
まあまたあるが合体してね
まあとにかく念仏さえ唱えれば
まあ極楽道に生まれますよということだけで言っていて
定めとは言わないんですね
まあ仏教ですから ですからそのとこないんだけど
この不完全なところはもう強烈に言ってるんです
本当に死んでから極楽道に行かなかったら
もうどうしようもなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 今ここでやるということは
仏教で今ここでやって確かめてみるんだと
という考え 仏教的な立場は強烈に取ってるんですね
それでお釈迦様 私はこういう修行やってこういう清らかな心を作りましたと
もうやることはないんだと
自分がしっかりそれを悟ったと
その智慧は持ってるんだと
ですから そういう風に言っていて
だからそのために必要な
まあ心理学になってるんですね
ですから まあ心分析する場合も
このクサラダンマ アクサラダンマ
ヴィヤカタダンマと この現在我々体験している心の状態からもう説明始まるんですね
クサラダンマというのは
クサラっていうのはまあ善であって
まあ善というカテゴリーに入る法はなんですか？不善というカテゴリーに入る法はなんですかと
そういうふうに分けられないものは何ですかと
そういうふうに見ちゃうと簡単そうに見えますけど
アビダンマテキストのクサラダンマ読むともう悟りのところまでそこ入ってるんですね
普通の心から アクサラダンマの場合はもうほんの少々なんですけど
そこで分けられない方にいっちゃったらどういうことかというと
またまたいっぱい入ってあって
その中にも善の心も悟りの心もまた出てきたりしていて
そうすると普通の常識で読む人のとっても
頭がおかしくなってしまっちゃうんですね
何ですか 何ですか これはと
そこら辺を何とかしようと
この学生たちにこの勉強アビダンマ勉強する前にこういう項目を勉強して
この今我々読んでいるテキストはそういうテキストなので
この項目を勉強していくらかこの基礎知識を作りなさいと
それからアビダンマに入れなさいという風になっているんです
じゃあ今日始めているのは
その中でこのアクサラダンマっていうところなんですね
アクサラダンマの場合はほんの少々ですね
もう入ってるのはそんなにたくさんないんです
そこでわかりやすくしていますから
この世の中で何が悪いんですかと
世の中で道徳的に一般知識で聞くとバラバラなんです
ある国で悪いと思うものは
他の国で悪いと思ってない
ある時代で悪いと考えたものは
今の時代では悪いと考えていない
ですから ヨーロッパ的な倫理学というと
なかなかまとめられない
決められない はっきりしないです教えなんです
なんか読むともう難しくてもうもうキリがなくて
あれもこうだ これもこうだ
あれでこうで そういう話ばっかりでもうもうもう何かしっかりこれこれというふうなこと出てこない
どういう風になってますかというと
何かこの倫理的にこうしなさい
ああしてはいけないということは
言うことは倫理学者の仕事じゃないとそこまで言ってるんですね
ただむちゃくちゃ物事を喋ること
書くことだけ自分の仕事だと思ってるんで
そんなことを書いても人の役に立ちませんだから
ですから このモラリティという
もうEthicsという言葉で出てくるヨーロッパの哲学っていうのは
もうただの時間の無駄ではないかなと思いますよ
勉強したっても で 例えば聖書だったらもっと簡単で
これこれするな これこれをしなさいと言ってるんだから
それさえ守れば一応生きるのが楽になっちゃうんですね
やるなということをやらないで
やりなさいと言ったことはやってしまっていればよろしいし
そこでコーランみたいな聖書を持ってくると
我々から見ればもうやりなさいと言ってることはまたちょっとどうかなと思ったり
例えば女性はもう全部体隠しておかなくちゃいけないし
それもうなんで女性だけ体隠すんですかと
なぜ男性は隠さなくてもいいんですか？とかね
聞きたくなっちゃうし
で まあいろいろありますけどね
教会に女性は行ってはいけないとか
キリストカトリック教の場合でも
やっぱり女性は教会に行っちゃうと頭をベールで隠してしまっちゃうんですね
今は結構自由ですから
ベールがなくてもちょっとした手のひらくらいの大きさのハンカチを頭のこれで
まあただ形式的に置くだけでもう終わりますけどね
で ああいうのはどこからなんで生まれたかとわからないんですね
みんなやるんですけどね
仏教では 仏教の倫理学では
やっぱりこの貪瞋痴という心の働き
3つ見つかって むさぼり欲と
それから怒りと それから無知
そういう 3つがあるんだと言えば誰にでもあるんですね
それは精神的な健康な人であろうと
健康でない人であろうと
みんなにあるもので それに基づいてやる行動は
まあ不善ですし 行動はどんな行動かっていうのは
そんなに特別に決めてない
それでも決めてあげた方がよろしいんだから
十善と十悪というものはもう一応まあできてるんですね
殺生するなとかね 盗むことはするなとか
で 殺生は怒りに基づいてやってるんだと
で よくしもない行為やら盗むことやら
やっぱり欲に基づいてやってるんだと
で そういうふうな この具体的な
こういうこういうことをするなと
するなと言っているものは
やっぱりまた普遍的なもので
どんな人間でもしたら悪い結果になると
じゃあ そういう風になっていて
そこでアビダンマではまたそういうのを扱いますし
今日はこの前終わったのはこの貪るに基づく心の分析なんですね
で 我々から見れば 貪りというのは欲であって
いろんな欲がありますけど
で 食べ物に対しても 着るものに対しても
いろんなものに対して欲があります
勉強したいという欲もありますし
欲はたくさんいろいろありますが
それによって心はいっぱいありますと言っちゃうと勉強はしにくいんだから
すごい簡単に 8つのカテゴリーに入れてるんですね
欲があると心はまず喜ぶ
あるいは喜びがない状態
遮の状態 どっちかなんですね
心は悲しくはないんです
例えば音楽を聴きたい
音楽を聴いていると もう嫌で嫌でもう悲しくてというふうにはならないんですね
楽しいとあるいは楽しくないぐらいなんですね
で それからこれに あの
何です 見ですか 見という言葉が入っちゃって
見があるかないかと それで 8つに分けちゃうし
4つに分けちゃうし 喜びがある心と喜びがない心
遮の心と それに見があるとあるか見がないかと
それで 8つになってしまうし
見というのはまたその一つ心にある特別な特色で
この物事をちゃんと理解していない
ただ見たままで感じたままで
その通りだとすぐ決めてしまう
大体物事は確実に存在するんだという
あの見という邪見でもいいし
意見でもいいし 人間の心にいつでもあるんです
いわゆる無常と反対なんですね
全ての生命は無常だけは理解してないんです
みんな理解しているのは
無常の反対の物事は常にあると
という理解は一般的なんです
全ての生命に共通しているんです
それは嘘ではないということはわかります
みんな永遠という概念が好むし
この概念であって 哲学宗教はこの永遠になる
いかに永遠になるかという教えなんです
ということは 無常は分かってないんですね
一切は無常であると分かったら
永遠という概念は単なる自然に消えてしまうんですね
だから魂論もそこから生まれてきたんです
別に自己とか自我とか自分とか
そういう言葉を使っても悪くはないんです
極々自分を示すために
まあなんか魂はもう明らかにしなくちゃとか言ったっても
一般論として一般の言葉として使っても決して悪くはないんです
でもそれは特別な実体的な存在だと思うのは人間の希望であって証拠はない
哲学的に発展しているのはヒンドゥ教ですけど
ヒンドゥー文化の中で我論というのはインド文化なんですね
それはインドでしかどこにも世界で発展してないんです
魂について語ること これも私もかなりもう 40種類ぐらいまとめてまとめたことを覚えていますけど
経典の中から魂についていろんな宗教家が話していること
それはインドの思想でしか見つからないんです
例えばヨーロッパの宗教家から見れば
魂ってどんなものかというと
みんなわかってないんですね
全然説明はないんです
精霊 精霊というだけで
あれは大きいものか 小さいものか
普遍なものか 無辺なものか
それに身体があるかないかとか
何にも説明出てこない
ですから昔は精霊っていうのは大事なものですから
人は死んじゃったら丁寧に埋めておく
また復活しますから それで埋葬する場所がなくなっちゃうと
まあやむを得ず火葬するようになってしまったところで
魂はそんなもう火で焼けちゃっても焼けるもんじゃないか
すぐもう考え方変えてしまうんですね
だからいい加減といえばいい加減なんですね
何かはっきりした教えがないんです
そこでインドの世界では
やっぱり一つの魂論を破っちゃうと
より違う魂論を作っちゃう
インドでは最初は体そのものが魂だと思っていたんですね
そこで仏教やら他の宗教で体っていうのは壊れるでしょう
手首なんかはね 昔の王様たちは平気で人の首やら切ったり
手を切ったりしましたからね
そんな簡単に切って捨てられるものだったら
もうそれは魂って言えますか？体じゃなくて
また じゃあそれだったら他のものを人間の感覚やと言っちゃったんですね
感覚で言ったところで感覚って何ですかね？今は痛くて次にもう楽しいではないかと
そんなにちょっとしたことで変化するものを魂と言えるんです
感覚ではなくて 人間の
そうですか この思いとかね
そういうものだと いわゆる積み重ねると経験のようなものにと
それは仏教でサンカーラですか
このそういうような言葉で言ってますけど
色受想ですね 想という入ってるところにそこになってしまったんですね
そういうもので我々の思いにしたっても
もうそれ忘れちゃう 自分の母でも長い間会わなかったら顔も忘れてしまうんですよ
それは全くその通り 例えばまあまあ 6歳ぐらい
5歳ぐらいの子供が母から離れて 20年
30年生活したところで
どうやってお互いに分かりますか？全くわからないんですね
ですから 人の覚えっていうのは勉強したものを忘れちゃうし
自分の名前さえもたまに忘れちゃうし
で ボケてしまっちゃうし
そういうことをよく見えてるんだから
やっぱりそうは魂 そんなものはそうは魂かといえば
いえ そうは魂ではないとまたなっちゃってまして
そこでこの人間持ってる機動力というか衝動というか
もう元気に生きたいということはあります
それはサンカーラですね
仏教では行というんですね
それは魂になってしまって
それで仏教はそれに反対して
人間のこのエネルギーという
そういうものをもうあったりなかったりとかね
やる気があったり やる気が全く消えたりとか
それで何かやろうとしたっても
すごく勢いでそれをやる人も
まあやらなくちゃいけないんですかというふうな感じでやる人もいますから
様々なんですね そこですごい勢いで仕事する人でも
いきなりもう全部元気が失ったりして
エネルギーがなくなったりするということだから
それ魂と言えるんでしょうかと
聞いちゃったら そうじゃなくて色ですよとなっちゃうんですね
魂は知るものであって
なんだかんだ言っても知るのが魂でそこになってしまった
そう言ったら またそれはもう知るものによって変化するんだから
バラの花を見たら ゴミ箱を見たら
またそれなりに我々の心は変わってしまっちゃいます
そんなものは心と魂とは何で言うんですか？と言ったら
それでも魂じゃないんだと
言って 仏教ではこの受想行識は我に非ずというのは徹底的に言ってるんですね
なぜそう言ってますかというと
やっぱりインドの社会ではそのその段階で我論が発展したんだからなんです
で それからヨーロッパで仏教を研究した学者たちがこう言うんですね
それでインドにいた有名な学者で大統領であった人なんですが
ラーダクリシュナンという人が同じくお釈迦様は我を否定していないんだと
日本だったらもう中村先生をはじめ日本の学者って同じこと言ってるんです
で いわゆる人の言うことを繰り返す言うだけで自分で研究しないんですよ
学者っていうのは 日本の学問っていうのは
ヨーロッパで誰かが何か言っちゃったら
それをそのまま日本語で書くだけのことで
自分で研究しているしないんです
ヨーロッパで 特にイギリスで発展した仏教学問では
インドのラーダクリシュナンの考え方